he is entering his 13th season as head
coach of the New Orleans Saints and he
is the man of the instant replay our he
is coach Sean Payton how are you coach
rich good appreciate you having me on no
come on
anytime always enjoyed chatting with you
how are you able to pull off the instant
replay rule that was quite something
right there last week I think man to
credit all the parties involved it was
it was a process and I think one of the
things that Rich McKay did that was
outstanding early in the meeting week he
really just went through the room you
know in our general session and that
would be the owners the general managers
the head coaches along with the
competition committee and in really you
know started with open dialogue before
even getting to a proposal because look
there were four or five different club
proposals and then a couple competition
committee meeting proposals all directed
at you know how we can how we can be
better on game day and so it really
started with an open dialogue amongst
the clubs and then during the lunch hour
you know putting together maybe what we
heard in in that meeting as a committee
as a competition committee and then also
with the Commissioner Goodell as input
you know we we kind of arrived with
something that it took us a little
longer than maybe expected and yet we
felt like something that that can work
with with with our officials and in our
league and that was the neat part about
it just overall the the positive
discussion and back and forth and I felt
everyone in the room was was just
wanting what was best for our league and
so there weren't any hidden agendas if
you will or any you know was really out
how can we improve in this area and and
that that's the reason I think everyone
felt so positive coming out of that
meeting
well what put it over the top because I
mean Stephen Jones is on
show literally a week after the NFC
Championship game and and was already
talking about how there's unintended
consequences and we've got to be careful
John Elway said the same thing there on
the competition committee in the same
meeting rooms as you you're on that
committee what what eventually changed
people's mind to get a thirty one to one
well I think a couple things stuff one
of the proposals there were three of
them if you will six proposal called
number six then there were 6a and 6b
there's three separate proposals if you
will and at one point six B was
gathering some momentum the only problem
with that inside two minutes it was
going to allow the coaches to continue
to challenge play well and what we
didn't want is every game ending you
know with the Hail Mary that was getting
challenged to see if there was contact
and you know we're real mindful of not
changing the flow of the game you know
our our challenges is as in in general
have been down coaches are challenging
less you know we have scoring plays now
and in in inside of two minutes and so
the numbers suggested that we aren't
challenging as much I don't think this
will this is going to add challenges to
our game because I think as a coach when
you know a potential dpi or OPI can be
challenged you're gonna you're gonna
want to make sure you hold at least one
you know towards the end of the game in
I think all of us have become a little
bit more judicious or patient if you
will challenging the 7-yard play maybe
you're one in which that you just don't
look at it the same way as you might
have when the system started so I think
you know that that session that we had
as a group you know Tuesday a.m. carried
a lot of weight and that was owners GM's
and coaches and I think then you know at
that at that lunchtime meeting with the
committee the competition committee I
think we felt like we arrived somewhere
that would that would work cleanly I
know this I know that we're not looking
at games with constant challenge flags
on the field look in it I mean you're
gonna have to be fairly certain that
that your player was either a interfered
with or not interfere with if a flag was
thrown so I think trying to avoid the
the big mistake was the goal of the
group in there and and I think that's
ultimately what what won out Sean Payton
here on the Rich Eisen show so what is
the criterion coming from the
competition committee about what is a
buzz about play in the last two minutes
certainly with the point of the Hail
Mary that you just made you could pretty
much do that every time inside two
minutes so it's going to replay and I
think replay is going to look just as
they currently do if it is something
that replay buzzes down to the head
referee it's going to go to New York I
think it would have to be something that
would be clear I don't think that you're
gonna see when it's in again for the fan
the challenge system and the way we do
replay is going to be the remain the
same so if it's north of two minutes in
a game first or second half it's going
to operate with a coach's challenge if
it's inside two minutes it's going to
come from our replay upstairs and I
think it's it's going to be something
that that they would look at clearly and
obviously and say hey take a look at
this in New York and then you know out
back in New York is gonna is going to
look at it and its entirety and make a
decision so I think to two parts to this
the the agreement to vote by our teams
and clubs and coming away from Arizona
was real positive the second part of it
though was the execution of it and and
I'm sure that we're going to spend a lot
of time on trying to look clearly it
ones that we see being overturned or
ones that that would not be and I think
that's the next part of the challenge
and what do you think this puts the
issue to rest in New Orleans do you
think that Saints fans seen this I mean
and it was important for me and the
committee it was important too to not
come in with a bias relative to a call
that just took place in our game but
really being on that committee I think
there's more of a responsibility overall
to the other 31 teams in that
responsibility of what's best for for
our game and so it wasn't about
specifically the New Orleans play
although look that play probably had a
lot to do with why we were discussing
replay and you know it if you looked at
it probably over a period of time was
due to happen or could happen again and
so it wasn't about that specific play it
was it was really what's the best way
that we can help the officials in batted
a little higher percentage it's not
going to be perfect going forward and
and I think that's what we did well I
mean and Peter Kings column on Monday he
quoted something that Jason Garrett I
think said to the entire ownership group
about how we had great games from the
AFC and NFC championship weekend you
know I was talking about us officiating
and it's somebody whose job it is to
talk football all the time on the NFL
Network I'm like you tell me about it
you know I mean so do you think that
rectifies everything the fact that this
is now the changes are in and I think we
you know to Jason's point he was
fantastic on Tuesday speaking man we had
two great championship games you know
the NFC and AFC championship game both
were overtime games I I think you know
was interesting is you talk about the
perfect time window you know call it
three hours one of the things you know
each each time you you go to one of
these meetings you learn a little bit
more and I think that although there's a
certain goal timewise for for these
games the one the one common theme is if
it's an exciting game no one's looking
down saying it's three minutes and 12
you know three hours and 12 minutes long
it's too long
I think eliminating the dead time is
something our league's done a great job
with and I and I do think that
look any time you come off of two great
games like that you you want more of the
topic to be about oh the last minute
Drive that Tom Brady had in in you know
in New England and overtime or the
back-and-forth play from the Rams and
the Saints how it started off and in the
Rams then closed the gap and and ended
up winning in in the final play of the
game so you know you're trying to avoid
may be that that egregious mistake
and yet I think that there's no perfect
system but I think going forward it's
being able to put a challenge on the
field if you if you feel like a true
errors been made you know in our game
versus Pittsburgh a few weeks prior
there was an interference called against
camara and it was clearly a mistake and
a mistake like that would be able to
correct it and and so you're still going
to come away from games you're not going
to have that perfect game but we do know
one thing in you know all the studies
the analysts would tell us that that dpi
and OPI is the one foul that can impact
a game a lot more than call it the rest
of the rest of the fouls that can take
place in a game and so you know we're
gonna have to work our way through some
bumps I'm sure in yet I think we can do
that and I think we've seen the CFL do
that a couple more on this subject
before you move on coach Sean Payton
here so when was the last time that you
had a day where this wasn't brought up
to you this subject that's a good
question
you know we travel in the offseason some
and now one of the great things is you
know our ability to use uber or you know
a car service different you know all of
us now can you know go to our phone and
get a ride here and there and I wish I
would have just brought a camera with me
and recorded every uber discussion I've
had in the last two and a half months
when the driver turns around and then
you know the one thing you realize is we
have a ton of NFL fans out there and and
so you know at times I wanted to wear a
hat and say look I'm aware of that I
agree with you
it would have saved a lot of discussion
but the fans are passionate and even
fans that clearly aren't Saints fans of
RAM fans are just NFL fans you know I
had a guy from from from Greece in
Indianapolis who who took me probably on
a six-block uber ride and and had strong
opinions as to how this all happened and
it's everyone's opinion on it varies
some in yet it's exciting that they're
fans of our game and I couldn't help but
notice also in Peter Kings column is
something that I had heard myself is
that a strong advocate for your position
on instant replay is somebody that you
are supposedly well-known for not liking
in the Commissioner of the National
Football League or is this some sort of
kumbaya moment here with you and Roger
Goodell and he was he was outstanding
and I like listen I I don't not like
Roger I like Roger and in being on this
committee you really it allows you
because because you meet so so long with
seven other members and then outside the
eight committee members there's another
you know 12 15 people that are that are
in those rooms doing a lot of hard work
a lot of legwork including the
commissioner and and you really get to
know the person a lot better than then
from afar just just as a head coach so
you know for me it's an honor to be on
that committee and I do feel that and
take that responsibility you know very
strongly and in he was fantastic
throughout this process even beginning
at Indianapolis when the the meetings in
Indy were just general discussions
knowing that we were going to be dealing
with this topic and then I his
leadership in Arizona last week was was
fantastic so he can have dinner in New
Orleans again can you take him out there
and just yeah absolutely not look he
he's you know what he he too wants
what's best for the game and in surely
as the Commissioner he wants to be at a
Super Bowl where
focus is on those two teams and it's not
sidewindin in any in any other direction
and I think he's got a good pulse of
barley and in certainly showed that I
felt in Arizona
rich he was fantastic not in agreement
really in problem-solving in in getting
a good pulse from that room in that am
meeting was was something that I I think
really helped him and helped all of us
move in a certain direction I mean
because if I had a dime for every time
that I've heard at an owners meeting
that the unintended consequences and we
can't do this with the cat rule we can't
do this with the Tuck rule we can't do
this we can't do this
I'd be a millionaire and the fact that
this got passed and it had to pass I'll
be honest with you you know I know you
and I have had a conversation off but
I'll say it here too there had to be
something to tell fans certainly in that
rabid city that you coach in for the
sport that they're heard we see it we
hear it something had had to be done and
this is a radical idea for a lot of
people they're already nervous that the
games going to take forever and all that
sort of stuff had to happen and I could
not be more glad that it did really well
I would say I would say number one it's
it's not going to change the length of
our game where our challenge challenges
are already down and I think to that
point we are as coaches going to be a
little bit more guarded with a challenge
flag that we might normally throw
because we've got this this additional
call that can be far more damaging in a
game it's not made correctly I think
secondly you know the the sometimes the
the fear of kings or hey we might be
going down this path and in discussing
that and then quickly saying well what
concerns you more making change like
this or having that repeat itself let's
just say in the Super Bowl in the final
minute and 30 seconds and then I think
very quickly you can look at it and say
hey look we can do this and we can do it
effectively and I don't think for a
second it's going to impact the
length of the game or the flow of the
game at all I think the challenge is is
strictly the consistency which we look
at these plays that's going to be the
challenge in the bar which we officiate
these plays not on the field our
officials are doing that in real time
but the bar in which we look at these in
New York when they come to New York two
more things for you before I let you go
I know we've been talking a while but I
appreciate it so your comments to my
colleague Steve White's about hiring
coaches in sort of a copycat way looking
for the next Shawn McVeigh raised a few
eyebrows certainly since obviously you
were a young coach with an offensive
mind set a long time ago not too long
but that raised a few eyebrows d-did you
hear some of the blow back on that and
do you what are your well I think lost
years all the I saw the hit on Twitter
in the the challenge with that is you
really have to look at the whole
interview and the interview was really
about diversity in our hiring and look
it was a tough year for diversity when
you currently look at our general
managers 32 GM's in the league and and
our head coaches in the league and you
know that that has to be better there
there's some fantastic candidates so it
really wasn't directed at all at any one
of the new hires but the point being is
look it's hard enough to find the right
head coach fit in all of us understand
you know you really have three years to
prove yourself it's a you know it's a
we're changing coaches roughly at about
a 25 percent clip eight coaches a year
and and so history's told us those
successful head coaches don't have to
just come on offense I mean are you not
interested in the next Bill Belichick or
the next Tony Dungy I was trying to
reference the the overall the leadership
that we're looking for and and he takes
a guy like David Shaw who I worked with
the Eagles and he's doing a great job at
Stanford and he wants to stay in college
I think I've heard I don't know this
first
that he doesn't not interested in the
NFL and yet when does that ever stopped
us in the NFL you know it in in if if
we've had a strong conviction we as an
ownership group for a certain team
they've gone and gotten a coach and so
the topic was just our diversity in in
right now I think that look if I was in
a position where I was looking for the
for a head coach if I was in the general
manager seat I would certainly not want
to eliminate half the candidates because
they worked on one side of the ball of
the other and I would not want to
eliminate the candidates certainly
because of their age or their race I I
would be trying to find which is a very
difficult task the the best leader that
I think could could lead our team to not
just in the short term but in the long
term you know successful sustainability
which is what we're all looking to do
and it's a little bit easier said than
done and and so that when you get just a
little piece of it it's really not the
whole interview and the interview
started with just us as a league and I
think we'll be better there last one for
you coach I would be remiss if I did not
ask you on April 1st somebody who has
pulled many a prank in his day give me
your best one what he got for me well
rich the the first one that comes to
mind was in April first it was the heat
of January in the post season when I'm
in Seattle sitting in my room and and
and and we're getting ready to play the
Seahawks we've got what five hours
before we even begin to think about game
time yes cutting around the league to
the various cities because of because of
the weather and there's Network in
Seattle with Brees and Russell Wilson
warming up on the field in their
t-shirts but nonetheless at the stadium
and I'm in my pajamas in bed thinking I
should be handing the officials the
inactives right now I overslept so that
wasn't an April Fool's Day somebody
rolled the wrong button rolled tape I
know you texted Marshall and I at the
same time on the set see
I stuffed my toe going into the shower
we were in Bellevue which meant that we
were a half an hour away drew and
Russell were warming up pregame
literally all the busses had left and so
that was the one that felt probably most
like your worst nightmare as a coach
you're late the only thing worse would
have been they were playing the national
anthem well what about the time at the
Pro Bowl where you got Tony Romo and his
first Pro Bowl appearance to cough up
his room number to your child right
remember that happened yeah so that was
those six and it was the first time I
ever attended the Pro Bowl we were
coaching the NFC's team we had back then
the Pro Bowl was after the Super Bowl we
had lost to the Bears in the
championship game it was Tony's first
Pro Bowl
he was just finished starting with the
Cowboys and Connor my son at the time
was six years old and you know a big
football fan and we were all in Hawaii
and the first day is is a day where
there's a lot of meetings you're not
practicing and players are in the room
signing footballs
you know getting a lot of the logistics
out of the way and Larry Allen the
fantastic player that I don't know how
many Pro Bowls he played in but Larry
was one of those quiet guys but I had
heard from from other players in years
past that you know that they all were
they were all looking for a room number
so they could put all their meals or
drinks on a certain number you know a
rookie player and so in that meeting
quietly I just grabbed Tony I said hey
Connors made a picture for you he's
excited to see is there a roomie he can
deliver it to and Tony right away you
know 638 and at that moment Larry Allen
was signing a football I want you to
just picture his eyes just raised up
looked at me kind of winked and and went
right back down to sign in southern the
next day Tony Tony had to switch rooms
it exceeded its incidental allotment
you're the best coach thanks for the
time well chat soon alright guys thank
you guys Sean Payton the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience